now Mark Daniels is the sheriff of
Cochise County in Arizona and he's
joining us to share what's really
happening there with these containers
sure thanks so much you're standing
there in front of these containers uh
this has become a point of conflict you
guys are trying to secure the border and
stepping up where the federal government
has failed and now the federal
government is coming in and saying no
you're not allowed to do that
that is correct and thanks for having me
Tulsi and Governor Ducey has stepped up
he's for the last eight years government
Ducey has made his priority Public
Safety in the state of Arizona protect
the arizonians and I commend him for
that uh President Biden uh doj has come
forward and said and sued the State of
Arizona for trying to protect the
citizens of this state and I'll say this
to you Tulsi this intellectual voidance
with intended consequences which is an
open border by design by President Biden
by the leadership within Congress has
placed my citizens in my County at risk
and I'll give you an example what I mean
by that since January of this year until
about a week left here and this year
we've arrested close to 1500 people been
booked in my county jail for
state-related Border crimes over 500
victims of felony crimes in my County
my 38 years of law enforcement this is
the worst I've ever seen it
it's it's hard to imagine for a lot of
folks who aren't living there kind of on
the front lines of this crisis as you
are what what recourse do you have there
as you're trying to do your job you and
your team while the federal government
is frankly interfering in your ability
to keep your community safe
well the best part of being a sheriff
and my my colleague shares a 3 000
sheriffs in this country we're elected
by the people I I work for the people of
this County and to keep them safe and
enhance and embrace their quality of
life I won't give up my oath of office
and I'll continue to support the rule of
law here in Cochise County I asked
though and I welcome that partnership
with President Biden leadership in
congress our Governors to continue doing
the job for America and that's under the
oath of office Tulsi and that is we've
got to protect our borders we've got to
protect our country
Sheriff thank you so much for your
leadership and for reaching out to those
whether they're Republican or Democrat
across the state and nationally in
Washington and encouraging them to step
up and do their job as you are trying to
do yours thank you so much
thank you Chelsea Happy New Year
you too hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else